انا يعني واجهت موقف صراحه غريب جدا من ام
كانت تولد وتفاجات بانه بعد الولاده طلبت
من الاب ان هو ياخذ الطفل وبدل ما هي
ترضعه الاب يحمله على
صدره وكان هو اللي
[موسيقى]
يرضعه انا اشواق العمران قابله في مهنه
القباله صارلي تقريبا اكثر من 20 سنه
اشتغلت طول الفتره اللي راحت هذه في يعني
غرفه الولاده بالتحديد اللي هو مكان عمل
القابل الحقيقي درسنا قباله كخمس قابلات
سعوديات اول خمس قابلات سعوديات في عام
1989 وكنا اول دفعه قباله في السعوديه
لدرجه ان احنا لما جينا نتخرج من الجامعه
قالوا لنا التخصص هذا ممكن ما يكون فيه
مسمى في وزاره الصحه ولكن لله الحمد على
اخر سنه افكت الازمه و وجدوا لنا اسم
القابله اللي هي قابله قانونيه
وبعدها اتقفل القسم ما عاد في
قابلات في القديم ما كان في دكتور نسا
وولاده كانت في دايه الدايه تقوم بعمل
الولاده اللي هي القابله الحين يعني انا
اقول انا انا مو مذكي ولكن انا القابله
اللي اخذت تاريخ مرضي للام وعارفه ممكن
ايش يصير معاها ببدا معها تمارين رياضيه
خاصه ب عضلات البطن اللي هي
بتهيئه تهيئه كامله لولاده طبيعيه انا
بجيبها غرفه الولاده وبحطها على سرير
الولاده وبقول لها يلا ابدائي وكانك انت
تولدين اعمل لها تطبيق عملي الى الولاده
في غرفه الولاده لحد ما تولد فتره النفاس
برضه انا لي علاقه فيها اطمئن على كل شيء
بالنسبه
للام مع الطفل مع الرضاعه الطبيعيه
طبعا الدكتوره تقوم بعمليه الولاده كامله
الدكتوره ممكن حتى في الخاص ان الدكتوره
تجي تولد ما تولد القابله لكن
القابله موجوده ملاصقه ملاصقه تامه للام
بالعكس الحكومي القابله موجوده هي مع الام
وهي اللي تولد ما في دكتوره تجي تولد فهي
تولدها القابله معاها لحد فتره الولاده
لحد ما تسمع البيبي خرج منه وهي موجوده
معاها الطبيب يقوم بعمليات الولاده
الجراحيه زي ما قلنا سواء كان قيصري او
ولاده شفط او ولاده بالجفت كلها لازم تكون
عن طريق طبيب القابله غير قادره انها تقوم
بهذا الامر غير مصرح لها مش م
[موسيقى]
قادره احنا لازلنا بنواجه حالات في غرفه
الولاده
بتميز التواريخ معينه خلال السنه انه انا
ابغى اولد في هذا التاريخ 8 8 9 ت
اوكي يوم الوطني فانا مو اختار جنس
المولود اختار التاريخ كمان الام قررت لها
الدكتوره مثلا الولاده في شهر 8 فقالت لها
الدو ديت حقك مثلا حيكون ما بين 15/8 الى
30/8 عندنا اسبوعين ممكن اقرر على اساسها
ادخل
لتحريض تحريض حيساعد ولاده
الطفل بعد التحريض مباشره او انه اقرر لا
والله من اولها كت عمليه عشان اولد في هذا
التاريخ احنا معاناتنا في التواريخ
المميزه ذحين انا حاطه حساب اشوف الجدول
عندي يوم 9 ت مين حيكون عندي من الاستاف
لان انا اتوقع عدد الولادات
[موسيقى]
تكون وجود الزوج في غرفه الولاده مع الام
مهم جدا انا ك خبله اقول لك مهم لانه انا
اشوف الدعم النفسي اللي يقدمه الزوج مجرد
وجود ده ترى بعض الازواج جالسين على
الجوال وزوجته تولد لكن مجرد وجود الزوج
معاها تحس بدعم نفسي خليني اقوللك انا
قابله اواجه يوميا في غرفه الولاده حالات
ولاده فتقولي ما اعرف مثلا الام تقوللي ما
اعرف ادفع كيف ما اعرف اقوم انا اعمل لها
براكتس يعني يعني يعني تمثيل يعني خذي نفس
عميق اكتمي نفاسك وابدا يدفع هو يسمع
معانا طبعا هو جالس يسمع معانا فلما يجي
تطبيق وقت الولاده نقول لها يلا خذي نفس
عميق ابداي ادفعي بسم الله واحد انين 3 هو
قوم يدفع معاها هذه امور بالعكس لما احنا
نشوفها نحس انه مهم وجود الزوج خليه يشوف
خليه يحس معاك بالالم عشان لما لما تقولي
انا ابغى اجيب طفل ثاني او اقوللك يلا
جيبيلي طفل ثاني ترى انا
عانيت خليك
[موسيقى]
معي سف في امهات كثير جدا بيجون مستخدمين
بعض الاعشاب اللي في نظرهم بتساعد على
عمليه الطلق وبالذات الناس اللي بيستخدموا
الحلتيته هي يعني عشبه مشهوره عندنا في
السعوديه ومشهوره بين الامهات وانتقلت الى
البنات البنات الان جايات في عمر صغير
واشوف قدامي بدل ما اشوف المويه قدامي
اشوف
حلتيت قلت لها هذا
ايش قالت لي هذا حلتيت قلت لها يا حبيبتي
ليه اخذتي الحلتيت قت لا ما اخذته انا
شميته للاسف معظم الامهات ما تعرف مضار
ولا اي مستوى ممكن يوصل المضار المتعلقه
بشم الحلتيت ممكن توصل لا سمح الله الى
انفجار الرحم عند بعض الامهات والله من
يوم تدخل واشوف كذا قايل السيده متالمه يا
بنتي اخذت شي قالت لا حطيتوا لها طلقه يا
بنات لا ما حطينا لها اج مش ماخذه الا
ماخذ حلتيته تسكت ماخذ حلتيته اي احترفي
قالت اي ماخذ
[موسيقى]
خلاص انا يعني واجهت موقف صراحه غريب جدا
من ام كانت تولد وتفاجات بانه بعد الولاده
طلبت من الاب انه هو ياخذ الطفل وبدل ما
هي ترضعه الاب يحمله على صدره و وكان هو
اللي يرضعه شال ملابسه اللي فوق بس وحط
البيبي على صدره مباشره وكانه يرضعه فكان
غريب بالنسبه لي بصراحه ولكن في نفس الوقت
كان مثير الى اني اعرف السبب فانا سالتها
بعد الولاده بعد ما قامت بالسلامه وامورها
تمام فجيت سالت قلت لها حابه اعرف يعني
السبب انت ليه ليه فضلتي هذا الامر فقالت
لي انا من باب تحمل المسؤوليه لزوجي انا
احب ان زوجي شاركتي المسؤوليه في كل
شيء
فانا ودي ان زوجي يقدر يرضع الطفل بس طبعا
هو ما يقدر ولكن انا ابغى الطفل يتعود من
البدايه على صدر ابوه علشان هو يتحمل جزء
من المسؤوليه معاي في حمل الطفل انت تعرفي
طبعا انه البيبي لما يشم ريحه الام يبدا
يتعود عليها اوكي يعرف امه من ريحته من
ريحتها فهو لما يعرف الاب من ريحتها حيبدا
يتعود
عليه يعني هي هنا البوينت حقتها
[موسيقى]
فقط هي ما لها اي علاقه بالولاده ك طبيا
يعني انه لازم انه يكون عندك مويه دافيه
ولكن في الافلام او في الممارسات القديمه
احيانا تولد السيده في الجو البارد فيكون
الجو مره بارد ايش يسووا سخنوا مويه وحطوا
الفوطه حقت البيبي في المويه بحيث انه لما
يخرج البيبي يلقوها في فوطه دافيه لكن هل
هي حقيقه علميه احنا لما درسنا هذا الامر
ما في شي يقول ان المويه الدافئه حتجيب لي
طلق بالعكس المويه الدافه حتري حني من
الطلق فانا بالطريقه هذه انا قاعده اريح
نفسي شويه من الطلق بحيث انه انا اساعد
نفسي اتجاوز مرحله الالم فكانوا اللي
يسووه صح بس اللي يهدف لا
غلط معظم الامهات يجوني مرعوب وبالذات اول
اول حمل
مرعوب بنت خالتي صابها كذا اختي ولدت
وصابها كذا وحبيبتي انت ايش اسمها اختك
قالت ساره انت ساره اسمك قالت لا قت طيب
اللي صار لها بصير لك لا طيب ليش تقولي
كذا قلت لان انا اعرف انه احنا بس نسوي
واحد اين 3 حيروح في مسكنات وفي ابره
الظهر يعني ولاده بدون الم نهائي انت
تقدري تولد بدون ما تحسي ولا بنتف الم
اكثر شي يخوف الامهات اللي يجوني يقولو لي
انا خايفه من الم الولاده طب الم الولاده
احنا عرفناه حيروح بتدريب وحدر بك وفعلا
اعمل لها برنامج وادرب
اوكي ايش بقى قالتلي خايفه كيف يخرج
البيبي طيب حدر بك حعمل لك تطبيق عملي كيف
حيخرج البيبي انت بتكوني موجوده ايوه انا
كمان بكون موجود ها ايش بقى زوجي يقدر
يدخل مع ايوه زوجك يقدر يدخل معك ايش بقى
خلاص انتهت الولاده قلت والله خليتيها لي
سهله على اني اسمح دائما ان انا بخاف
الولاده الكل يقوللي وخوفني والولاده
المها صعب وانا عانيت بس انا افهم قنيه
اللي بتساعدني على كيف اتحمل الم الولاده
واتدرب له انا حاديها ان شاء الله شوفي
اجمل موقف انا
واجهته في حياتي
العمليه
انه اتفاجا
بسيدات يقولو لي انت اللي ولدتي بنتي او
ولدي وهذه بنتي قدامي تكون البنت عمرها
تسع سنوات عش سنوات يعني جميل جدا المشاعر
انك تعيشيها انك كنتت سبب سعاده انسان في
وقت الم بعد ولاده كنت اول من مسك هذا
الطفل اول من داعبت يدك يده لحظات جميله
جدا نعيشها مع الامهات و وبالتالي نشوفها
بره بعد عشر
سنوات مشاعر لا توصف
بصراحه مره
ثانيه شكرا
ok